it's time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of the
important issues of the hour brought to
you every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene this is David Ross may
I introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching promise scope
Larry lesser of the CBS television news
staff and Merlin Pitts early labor
editor of Businessweek magazine our
distinguished guest for this evening is
Dave Beck general president of the
International Brotherhood of Teamsters
Union AF of L they call our guest
tonight businessman with a union button
well as boss of the largest and most
powerful union in the United States he
believes that a giant union should be
run like a giant business like u.s.
steel or General Motors mr. Beck your
union controls everything from the
delivery of diapers to the driving of a
hearse and if you tell us what you think
of the economic picture right now well
in my opinion we're in a very serious
economic condition in this country and
in my personal judgment are in we are in
a recession and could very easily go
into a serious depression
well mr. Fech everywhere all the
economic soothsayer think we're on the
verge of coming out of whatever
recession we were in well it's my
personal opinion that we are not on the
eve of coming out of it at all and I
personally believe that if it were not
for the tremendous amount of money
that's being pumped now in through the
payment of unemployment insurance we
would be in a very serious economic
position and with a great deal more
suffering among the unemployed mr. Beck
you mentioned in mentioning unemployment
insurance you touched on one of the
public welfare aspects of
Affairs which you feel support the
economy I wonder whether I'd like to
hear your comment on a criticism which
is heard occasionally these days from
certain labor quarters that the
President of the United States mr.
Eisenhower is anti labor do you think
President Eisenhower's anti labor I
definitely do not think so I think
President Eisenhower is not anti labor
though I do not agree with all of these
policies and the men that surround him
in every instance but personally I say
very definitely no he is not anti labor
well mr. Beck do you think that this
pump priming through the paying of
economic of unemployment insurance is
going to bring us out of any recession
we might be in right now I think very
definitely the only way we can come out
of this recession is by the process of
priming the pump and putting money into
general construction and every avenue of
self-liquidating projects even though
they take a considerable period of time
to amortize at an interest rate that
will give them an opportunity to get the
business machine underway and give
employment out of which can will develop
consumer purchase and from that more
employment mr. Beck you don't wait just
a second you don't have such little
confidence in the enterprise system in
America do you that you think the only
way we're coming out of what you call a
recession is for the government to
spoon-feed and pump prime the economy I
advocate of course and I'm a great
advocate of the philosophy of free
enterprise of course but I think under a
condition confronting us now until we
can get that free enterprise system
functioning it's going to be necessary
for assistance from government now I did
very definitely state that this money
should be pumped into self liquidating
projects which means that much of it
should be given to the avenues of
private enterprise and private financing
on those projects and over a period of
time will liquidate themselves even
though
it takes longer than normal to amortize
mr. Beck you saw the president very
recently is this what you told him
that's the advice you gave him no I did
not talk with the President on this
subject matter I talked with him on my
recent trip to Europe well what'd you
tell him about that did you feel that
they were doing well over there I talked
with him on the questions of communism
in Europe the necessity of the federal
government of all governments taken
recognition of the fact that if we're
going to destroy communism we must do it
by developing an economic situation
among the people to improve their
standards because you do not make
communists from men of material wealth
men that are incubated into the lap of
communism are those people who and
desperation are turning in every
direction because of their economic
condition mr. Veeck do you think that
you think that communism is a problem
anymore in America you think the
Communists have any influence any longer
in the American labor movement I do not
think so I think communism in the
American labor movement is of no
importance whatsoever at this time
though I do not think for one second
that we should ever keep our eye off of
it
and should always be on our guard but
again I want to emphasize the splendid
economic position of America for the
labor and in common people of this
country is so far transcends that of any
other country that we are not the
fertile ground for incubation of
communism
well mr. Beck you're the boss of a very
big Union million three hundred thousand
members I believe now I think there are
a number of unemployed in the trucking
industry right now what would happen if
communists work into some of your locals
well if communists got any real foothold
in our local unions they would do the
same damage that they were doing any
other local union so we make it our
business to see that they do not well
what about the other shall we say twin
evil that has beset the American Lane
movement racketeers what about if
racketeers get in or if there are
racketeers in locals or divisions of the
Teamsters Union what authority do you
have is General President to deal with
that problem I think I have sufficient
authority to deal with racketeering and
there's no one can possibly condone it I
am NOT here to say that from time to
time racketeering may not creep into
labor unions but it is also creeped into
business we've had people in the
Penitentiary's that were bankers and
insurance brokers and every other phase
of our economic and social industrial
life but I say that racketeering would
destroy labor in the same degree that
communism would destroy mr. Beck you
have a very fine record in your a
particular union but I must confess that
some labor leaders think that you work
too closely with businessmen that you
tend to stifle competition and control
prices at the expense of the consumer
and what about that there's no truth to
that I certainly do work very closely
with the businesspeople that employ our
membership because in my opinion
industry must be prosperous it must get
a proper return on its capital if it's
going to continue in the status of being
able to give employment and I am
interested in every industry employing
our people because I know of no other
method by which they can get employment
other than through a prosperous industry
a bankrupt industry never gave
employment to anyone
Larry is quite right of course when he
says that one of the criticisms directed
against you is that your union works too
closely with businessmen but there's
another criticism which says just the
opposite mr. Beck namely that your union
is much too tough and that to deal with
when you when an employer deals with the
Teamsters Union he's taken on an awful
rough bunch of people what is the record
of the Teamsters Union in terms of
strikes and getting along with the
employers with whom they have contracts
well it's my personal opinion that the
record of the Teamsters Union on the
Industrial disturbances as fine as it's
possible to concede for instance let us
take the last six or seven weeks out of
a membership of approximately 1 million
three hundred thousand members we are
paying strike benefits to less than two
hundred men in the United States and
Canada heaven well mr. Beck there's also
another side to the union business
besides striking against employers and
that is a question of jurisdictional
disputes now what about this rating of
other unions do you approve of that I
certainly do not approve of the rating
of any other union and do not engage in
rating on unions we do insist upon the
preservation of our jurisdiction just
the same as the doctor does and the
attorney and everyone else that wants to
protect the lifeline of their operating
structure you've been in the news lately
mr. Beck
as the result of certain meetings in
Washington with David McDonald who's
president of the CIO Steel Workers Union
and John L Lewis who is president of the
Independent Mine Workers Union and one
of the popular interpretations that has
been put on that those meetings is that
you three eminent gentlemen of Labor are
trying to develop some kind of coalition
around which there might be rallied
other unions to start a third Federation
of Labor in America is there any truth
in there positively no truth in that
whatsoever none whatsoever
well mr. Baker I'd like to ask you about
a situation which is current right now
that is the situation on the waterfront
in the the great port cities
particularly in New York now do you
intend some people say to move in there
and try to get those unions in another
position take them within your own in
other words we only intend to take part
in organizing on these water fronts to
the degree that our jurisdiction is
involved the loading and the unloading
of trucks which is the jurisdiction
given to us by our charter from the
American Federation of Labor now we are
not interested in organizing
longshoremen or any other men that do
not come with
in the scope of our jurisdiction in
other words you don't intend to spread
your Union out into fields in which you
don't feel that you belong that's right
we do not well I'd like to ask you one
more question mr. Beck before you leave
do you feel that this economic situation
which you say is bad right now can't
improve in the near future I will not
say that it will improve in the near
future I will say that the basic
structure of American industry and the
economic stability of our country will
definitely find a way to pull out of the
present recession now how long that will
take I do not know but I definitely
advocate a recognition that we are in a
serious recession and that we use every
avenue of government and every means of
private finance and the cooperation of
Industry and labor with a recognition of
all of the problems revolving around it
and under those conditions this country
will very definitely pull out look thank
you very much Dave Beck for being with
us tonight the opinions expressed on the
launch in Crona scope were those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Khurana scope
was Larry lesser and Merlin pizza Lee
our distinguished guest was Dave Beck
general president of the International
Brotherhood Teamsters Union AF of L